Yeah
Five thirty-one
Now it's six twenty-one, yeah
Six-thirty, man I got to get up
But I don't want to get up
But me I no wan mess up
And I can never give up
I got the tunnel vision
And I'm on a mission
Got the energy noni
Now, you got some for me?
Oya, send me the funds
Call aunty now, yeah
And tell her we can go to South Africa
Yeah, yeah, yeah
Tell aunty now, yeah
That when I get the bag
We go to South Africa
Yeah, yeah, yeah
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yеah, yeah
Is it timе to get up?
Is it time to wake up now?
Yeah
Is it time to wake up?
Is it time to wake up now?
Sufferation make a boy like me
Go crazy, crazy
I look at my mother, sister, I said
"I cannot be lazy"
Church boy, na only huger fit
Make a brother go wickedy
Gangster no fit snitch on me
Me self I keep it secrecy
No go lie tell my people
If I make music, e gots to pay me
I dey my own side dey laugh
HipTV gimme the car
I talk say na me be the future
People dey look like say I dey cap
Oya, tell me the person
For this generation
Wey dey bridge the gap
Call aunty now, yeah
And tell her we can go to South Africa
Yeah, yeah, yeah
Tell aunty now, yeah
That when I get the bag
We go to South Africa
Yeah, yeah, yeah
I am the OG
Never take you from me
When you're the type that get me lonely
I am never foldin'
See what I'm holdin'
Now I keep it low-key
But they see me rollin'
Me, I no dey blow stick
'Cause I know the wrong thing, yeah
Call aunty now, yeah
And tell her we can go to South Africa
Yeah, yeah, yeah
Tell aunty now, yeah
That when I get the bag
We go to South Africa
Yeah, yeah, yeah
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah
Is it time to get up?
Is it time to wake up now?
Yeah
Is it time to wake up?
Is it time to get up now?
Yeah, yeah
Is it time to wake up?
Is it time to wake up now?
Yeah
Is it time to wake up?
Is it time to wake up now?